[Music]
welcome baby jumbo oil family here no
matter how small can we talk about the
elephant in the room you did not I did
really yeah somebody referred to
somebody without asking me earlier did
anyone on the set say can we joke about
the elf in their room but you're the
first person actually come in and have
the gold sorry can we take that's me and
I feel we should at some stage in our
four minutes talk about the elephant in
the room yeah there is two of them there
yeah so do I know this right about you
that you were a huge Tim Burton fan and
Edward Scissorhands was like one of your
because it's one of my all-time favorite
movies and it's yeah my youngest son's
favorite film as well really yeah yeah
so it spans generations yeah apparently
do you have a favorite scene it's been a
long time since I seen a know Edward
Edward oh she's so beautiful yeah she's
amazing so one of the premises of this
movie is the fact that the ears make
Dumbo stand out and he's ridiculed for
it in the beginning yeah but it becomes
the thing that makes him special and
unique and I feel like that's sort of a
like Hollywood you come to Hollywood you
want to be usually you want to be like
everybody else growing up and then what
makes you different what makes you stand
out was there anything that made you
self-conscious yeah it ended up being
your thing me yeah um
possibly yeah but I look we seem to be
quite often stuck between this desire to
be special and this desire to fit in
yeah and they don't have to be mutually
exclusive and at all both things can
quite loudly happen simultaneous because
not to be too tweet but I do believe
everyone is special and everyone does
have particular set of skills or virtues
and not everyone gets to find what those
are explore what they aren't that's
usually as a result of an oppressive
world however that may present itself
with family or schooling or whatever the
place and and this is a film that
explores the idea that difference
however extreme it may present itself to
be is something to be celebrated and
included and invited into the human
experience are the pocky thermic
experience and not something to be
shunned or excluded or treated cruelly
I'm gonna make another elephant
reference and that is elephants never
forget that's a matter of well-known
saying is there a what is a a memory
that you'll never forget taken from this
film memory this film that I'll never
forget and I I loved working with him
yeah yeah it just sucks just certain
it'd be boring I was just certain images
of him on the set I can remember very
clearly looking over and seeing him just
watching him watching him figure stuff
out and mull over stuff and walk around
pace and I just he was just he was just
so beautifully engaged and oftentimes
looked perturbed process but so so
beautiful to be around and he's such a
gorgeous man you know and such an
incredible imagination I mean there's
this picture that I don't know if I
found that if someone sent it to me and
it's him when he's a kid in a Hollywood
you know Halloween costume did you ever
see it and it's Jack skeleton no and
he's about nine or ten it's a prototype
for Jack skeleton I just thought he's
been dreaming this dream since then I
don't know I never asked him would he
need to know but he's been dreaming some
version of this creative otherworldly
dreams since then or expressing I don't
know if he's expressing his own sense of
isolation at times or what it is but he
certainly has a keen interest in what is
deemed as the other you know the
outsider yeah amazing is it true there's
the line in the movie that in show
business you should always have a rabbit
in your hat or a trick up your sleeve oh
yeah yeah yeah but there's always
tomorrow these days I'll get craft here
that could be the elephant in the room
yeah yeah you just expose me nothing
nothing
yes something very rare you have wonder
[Music]
you have mystique
[Applause]
you have magic
[Music]
come with me
together we can soar on the elephant's
wings
nice to see you can we talk about the
elephant sure yeah absolutely the only
time that amazing yeah yes yeah you talk
about the elephant can you wiggle your
ears I'm mad I was hoping somebody in
the cabinet I can't wiggle my ears well
there's there's a thing in the movie
about how everybody's got to have a
rabbit up their sleeve or in there yeah
do you have a key in a drawer yeah I do
I have him look in my drawer what's
yours well I can't show you what didn't
a monkey bite you on the set of come
back yeah yeah bit me in the mm-hmm yeah
it was good yeah we had no there was
only there were only I do you were seven
dogs and one snake on this movie on
Dumbo everything else was CG and it was
just a big green kind of like thing that
you watched but the big thing about the
doggies on the set I hung out with him a
little bit they were really cute but I
didn't go near the snake you know the
theme of this movie is that Dumbo what
makes them different ends up making him
special and wonderful exactly and did
you have anything that you felt are you
kidding me did I have anything I felt
different than other people and how did
you absolute how did you work it to your
advantage and how did you well the thing
about it is that I always felt a little
bit like kind of odd walking into a room
I was always a little rough around the
edges I was five feet tall I was like
you know in the wintertime you know you
know if I walked in a room you you might
think it was like some kind of like you
know kind of mysterious like maybe talk
to Jekyll and mr. Hyde mr. Hyde was
walking in and it was like very very you
know kind of like I was always skirting
to the background you know just be try
to be unnoticed and then then I found my
father I did my father is my acting yeah
that's what got me up in front of
everybody
yeah and the rest is just I know you
went to beauty school and you wore a
mask in this movie I love that you
embrace the mess so you're back with Tim
and you're back with Michael for the
first time since the 90s yes right and
one thing about me
returns and it's the three of us yeah I
did Johnny dangerously with Michael
before I met Tim and then you know and
then a couple more movies with Tim so if
elephants never forget what will you
never forget about this experience
oh I said all the movies that you do you
have like little kid bits like that you
remember but these are guys who were my
friends and now I have Colin as my buddy
and evergreen and all that you know
everybody in the movie is we were a
family circuses like that Dumbo is like
that Dumbo is a family thing that
doubles a family feeling need you to
believe it
you can do it Dumbo sure
[Applause]
fight among
so I'm making a joke with everybody
today do you want to talk about the
elephant in the room the elephant in the
room yes it would love to talk about but
there wasn't actually an elephant in the
room when you were filming right there
were things that was supposed to be done
but right like you had a cross sometimes
a tennis ball a man in the green suit no
a buck and Tim Burton sometimes was he
really sometimes he loves being Dumbo
he's completely identified with Dumbo
yeah he was in it wow I love it so your
trapeze and all your flying through the
air what what what did that actually
look like for you on the day like what
are you sitting on is there women I
trained I mean I don't really trained
yeah it was real dancer if I was done so
yeah no you weren't cuz it look like you
were I trained with you know like this
some aerialist and she's from ballet
background so she kind of helped me to
find some gestures and but it was it was
very intense to do some stuff up there
is the most difficult thing I've ever
done in my life really cuz I read that
you hated auditioning at one point that
you used to get nervous is that true or
not oh yeah auditioning oh yeah so what
was worse that or the thinking about it
it's gonna be cool the heights the
heights auditioning yeah yeah I don't
know similar horror wow wow how long did
you train for I trained for two or three
months and I am but they were did the
people were just amazing the circus
people they they love it so much it's
it's contagious and I I didn't want to
disappoint them you know they they put
so much you know they give you courage
and confidence and they really want you
want takeoff so if you were in the
circus what could what would be your
like fanciest trick that you could do I
mean now the thing that I prefer is to
be on this kind of Swing and and do kind
of things upside down and flips I kind
of know how to do that which is quite an
yeah I surprised myself
that's a major skill because in the
movie there's this line that says you
should always have a wrap it in your hat
in show business like you should always
have a trick mm-hmm would that be your
my new career would that be a trek or do
you have another
do you have any another no can you
wiggle your ears no I think everybody
today Jack Black can do it really well
he lookin yeah I think you have to be
born this way I think you dare to go I
think you do know was there because
Dumbo is you know what made him special
at the end of the day was that he was
different and that he had these ears and
I think this is this is one of those
businesses Hollywood is one of those
businesses where probably growing up a
lot of us want to fit in and then when
we come to Hollywood the whole thing is
how do you stand out is there something
that made you self-conscious ever that
you got teased about that became
something that you turned into an asset
god it's hard I mean it's a hard one
because I think you have to to be
individual I mean as an actor otherwise
they could hire somebody else you want
to be yeah a bit different and it is
quite paradoxical because I'm an actor
but I'm also very shy so it's kind of
like a difficult thing to kind of sell
yourself and to yeah it is quite a
strange thing I'm gonna have to go to a
therapist for that but yeah it's just I
embraced my shyness and you know I'm you
know Here I am talking to you and it's
it's you're very proud of yourself when
you overcome your fears yeah do you feel
like when you act do you lose yourself
in it or do you still feel that
sometimes do you still feel the shyness
coming in or is that your sort of ask is
that your way if I'm feeling free I
think when I'm on set and when i I've
done enough homework I kind of in
character I'm not shy kind of channel
everything in my character but it's more
you know in social life actually that I
sometimes struggle with it I got better
at it through the years but you know
that's four years it was a handicap for
me
but you know I this is where I am I'm
not gonna be loud and you know it's not
me I just you know you know that's it
Wow
and that's your ears those are your ears
those are my ears
you